so the house is that you're interested
on the market asking 310,000 you offer
300,000 so you make an offer contract
you dated you give all the pright
information you say what your offer is
you give a deposit to show that you're
in earnest that you're serious about
this but then you list your continue to
say hey look you know I'm want to buy
this house unless it doesn't pass
inspection unless I'm not able to get
financing unless I'm not to be able to
get insurance unless the the title is
somehow not clear and but if it all of
this does happen in the way in a
favorable way then we're going to close
two months in the future now the seller
has three options they could accept your
offer they could say okay you know I
agree to this offer contract and then
y'all will both sign it so this is you
know you could some put your signature
and the seller would put their signature
and so everyone agrees to this happening
and they'll sell and the your deposit
will essentially be taken and we'll talk
in a second about where that deposit
goes another option is that the seller
might just outright reject your offer
says no no this is an insult this house
has been in our family for forever
the 310,000 is my bargain basement price
I don't even want to I don't even want
to give credit to this offer by even you
know doing anything else so they just
reject it outright and then the third
offer the third option is that they
could give a counteroffer they say okay
this is close but I'm going to issue a
new counteroffer contract where instead
of it being three hundred thousand and
now that now it's the seller we're
talking about they'll say how about
three hundred five thousand or how about
fewer contingencies or how about a
closing date that is closer closer to
the period we're talking about or how
about the buyer takes on more of some
type of closing costs or some other type
of thing that's that's actually going on
so the seller is trying to give a
counteroffer that's in some way more
favorable to the seller and then the
buyer might look at that and either turn
it down or take it on and on and on and
on but let's just say for the sake of
this video that this offer contract is
accepted so if the offer contract is
accepted then then the buyer signs it
the seller signs it and they move
forward the transaction will move
forward and this essentially releases a
whole series of things that are going to
go on so let me see if I can diagram
that out so we are talking about a world
where the offer the offer is accepted
and so the first thing that is going to
happen is that you're going to have it
you're going to you have an opening of
escrow opening of escrow opening of
escrow and I know what you're thinking
what is escrow and I know you're
thinking that because I remember the
first time that I was involved in a real
estate transaction and I bought that
myself this word escrow kept popping up
over and over again and I had never seen
the word until I started having to deal
with this real estate transaction and
the whole idea of escrow let me scroll
this up a little bit is if you have so
if you have a buyer and a seller and
escrow actually applies beyond just real
estate but the idea becomes useful
anytime you're making a major
transaction for something that's quite
valuable maybe the transaction is a
little bit involved so buyer if you have
a buyer and a seller you might just say
you know the buyer might say hey give me
the keys to the house give me the keys
give me the keys and then I will give
you the money then I will give you the
money but the seller might say hey I'm
not going to give you the keys and when
I really say keys I'm really meaning
title to the house that's actually the
important thing keys locks can be
changed but give me ownership of the
house and then I'm going to give you
money and then the hotel says hey no no
this is a major asset this is a my
largest asset I have I'm not just going
to give you title until I get the money
first and then the buyer says oh no this
is like all the money I have I'm not
going to give you the money until I
until I get the title to the house until
I get ownership to the house first and
by the way I don't want to give you the
money until all of this other stuff
happens until I can until I until I can
inspect the house and do all of these
other things and it says anyway I don't
want to I don't want let you get all
these strangers into my house and
inspect it unless I know for sure that
you're going to buy it so you can see
that this can be this this could be a
little bit of a logjam they want to
transact but maybe they don't trust each
other or maybe they trust each other but
they're just afraid that maybe they you
know the one person might you know take
the title and run or one person might
take the money and run or they might not
be serious and so what society has
developed to solve this problem and it's
not just for houses it's for any major
transaction can be for businesses or
anything that could be fairly complex is
they turn to a third party a trusted
third party so let me write this down a
trusted a trusted third party third
party that is called the escrow agent
let me so this right over here is the
escrow agent escrow escrow agent and
when we're talking about escrow we're
talking about putting putting something
into a case you could say a third party
bucket an account and everything is
going to plea place there the buyer is
going to put all the things that they
need to place there the seller is going
to be place everything that they plays
there and then this trusted third party
can verify that both parties have met
their obligations and then it can give
the seller what the seller needs and
give the buyer what the buyer needs and
then essentially close that escrow
account so right when you start this
when we say opening of the escrow
account that means that so let's let's
say so this is the escrow agent and
they're essentially going to manage the
escrow account escrow escrow account so
as soon as the offer is accepted you
open an escrow account and that deposit
that we talked about that goes into the
escrow account so let's put that in so
that deposit that $9,000 that was in the
offer contract that goes into the escrow
account why is it important to get put
in the escrow account well if you gave
that deposit to the seller
well maybe the seller just cashes the
check but then later refuses to proceed
or not it doesn't allow the inspector to
come into the house or whatever else it
might be and so this is a way the buyer
can feel feel sure that okay I'm writing
this check but you know it's just not
going to disappear without me knowing
about $9,000 is not a small amount of
money and this way the seller feels good
okay
I trust this third party the buyer has
in earnest put the deposit there I know
the deposit is there so now I can unless
I can let the transaction proceed I can
let inspectors come into the house feel
good about it etc etc
and so as as we go through this period
as we go through this period between the
time that the offer was made this
two-month period it's not always two
months and the closing date the closing
data in the closing really is the
closing of the escrow account once all
of the parties have met their
obligations but in that two-month period
all the stuff is going to happen and so
you're going to have you're going to
have the inspection so House passes
inspection passes inspection the House
passes inspection the financing comes
through and the rest of the money for
the house gets placed here so financing
financing and so the financing so if
they say this person is putting 20% so
this was the 9k deposit actually let me
put some details here so there's the 9k
deposit now in order to actually have
the transaction we have to have a whole
three hundred thousand in there and so
let's say this buyer is going to put 20%
down on the three hundred thousand
dollar house so that's going to be sixty
thousand dollars they've already put 9k
this is often this deposit is usually
towards the down payment and so they'll
want to put another 51k down payment 51k
51k down payment and then the financing
comes through so this is going to be the
remaining this is going to be the
remaining $240,000 $240,000 from the
bank and there might be some other costs
on either side so these are kind of
closing when you call closing cost and
we'll do a whole videos on all of the
different types of closing costs but
these might be paying the agents paying
the mortgage brokers paying for the the
escrow services the title services the
title searches etc etc so so both sides
are going to put in their closing costs
so from the buyer and the seller and we
could talk about in different states
there might be different conventions or
even different transactions might have
different conventions for closing costs
and so on 1215 so you go all the way to
1215 we're assuming this is happening
in 20 and 2015 you have your closing
date and so the trusted third party this
escrow agent is going to say okay look
the buyer has put everything that that
they need to put in in order to buy the
house the seller has met all of their
obligations and the house has passed all
the inspection all of these
contingencies all of these contingencies
have been met so on the closing day on
the closing day this trusted third party
the escrow agent will actually disperse
the money so it will actually disperse
the $300,000 to the seller and will
actually issue the title which is the
ownership to the buyer and also pay
everyone else who has to be paid here
they might have to pay themselves
because they're one of the they're one
of the the services as part of this so
that will be involved in the closing
cost though it might pay the mortgage
broker the agents all the other people
who are party to this transaction and as
we've seen in the video on titles the
title is really about filing a deed so
filing a deed with the county or with
the city so this right over here would
would be a deed which essentially gives
the new owner the buyer proof that they
now own the property so the big idea
here is this whole idea of escrow is
just a way for a place to collect all of
the obligations of the different parties
so that they can trust each other and
then on the closing date and that's
really the close of escrow because you
don't need this escrow account anymore
it just disperses the different things
to the different parties so that the
transaction is complete